baggage claim here at terminal one is
busy as several flights land ahead of
the holidays now I spoke with many
people who decided to meet up here in
Las Vegas for Thanksgiving instead of
spending it at home
this the season for saving
as flight prices and gas prices
fluctuate Travelers are finding ways to
save what were her thoughts when we
first saw prices painful Sophie singer
and her family of five just landed from
California they're doing their annual
Thanksgiving trip a little differently
this year it would be about 10 grand so
I think this time around we managed to
get by with a six thousand dollar trip
the singer family is opting to not stay
in the strip but instead drive through
the nearest Canyons for the next six
nights the dampier family of 11 isn't
meeting up in Philadelphia this year for
Thanksgiving instead everyone flew into
Las Vegas but it was centrally located
for the bulk of us right now the only
thing that we've done is do Airbnb
instead of a hotel however some
Americans might be skipping out on
travel this year according to nerd
wallet one in 14 Americans who put their
2021 holiday travel expenses on a credit
card still haven't paid off those
balances it's definitely worth it but
for those like Bobby Todd finding the
best deals allowed him to join his
family for a holiday vacation in Las
Vegas I saved about 400 just on like a
vacation package versus like trying to
get my hotel and then my flight separate
now we all know holiday travel is very
busy and things could always change with
your Airlines so make sure to check for
frequent updates as well for now things
look pretty steady here at the airport
but tomorrow is expected to be a very
busy travel day Victoria Saha eight news
now